great to meet you I mean you have been
lucky enough to know Carol longer than I
think anybody else here anybody else
yeah she's my best Chum so I love that
as best charms what is something we
would be surprised to know about Carol
uh she brings out the worst in me and I
bring out the best in her I think that's
what best friends are for that's exactly
right yeah I love it now any chance of
you and Carol ever doing another project
together unless somebody could afford it
these days
[Music]
oh friend
we'd be delighted but we did three
wonderful specials and we hoped that we
could continue them but um I don't know
time and all other things just didn't
work out for us but we would have been
so happy well it's not for nothing you
both have been separately and
individually busy you're still working
oh they're busy and then covid came
along which was no help whatsoever right
well you know we are so excited about
the new season of Bridgerton and now
that we know who lady whistledown is my
name is Lady whistledown you do not know
me and rest assured you never shall is
there any chance we can get your iconic
voice to return oh definitely okay yeah
yeah you know what my next question is
what we have to do to get you physically
in front of the cameras to be in
Bridgerton no no no no you know who lady
Bridge lady whistle down really is so
I'm afraid it stays with me in the
background and yeah but I'm very happy
to do that any movement on Princess
Diaries 3 nope none okay not that I'm
aware of right you have to ask somebody
else
a princess shut up
[Music]
foreign